let me show you three one two three
three other strategies for how to go
about this okay so online item get rid
of this and you can go into your next
one
and what you can title this strategy is
it's it's it's always a simple strategy
this is called the nearest neighbor
strategy the nearest neighbor
okay now the nearest neighbor strategy
is about as obvious as it gets you just
pick any random starting point okay so
for example you might pick this one
that's my starting point and it's always
this is kind of a formula right it's
kind of formula because there is only
ever one nearest neighbor to where I am
and give a point so long as you can
measure accurately obviously sometimes
it's bit equidistant but frizzes you can
see there's clearly one answer which is
closest to this city right which is this
guy right that's the closest and then
you would get you roll out and you would
measure it out and it might be it might
be this one and then you look at the
next unvisited city than its closest
okay so I'm going to looks to be a trace
out this part here okay
now this part is different to the one I
came up with okay there is a very good
chance that it is better more efficient
than my first method by intuition okay
there's a good chance dere's name but
it's bullet guaranteed not a guarantee
so you remember how I said well it's
kind of its kind of like a formula but
it's not a foreigner what these things
are cold ah this is a weird technical
name and if any of you are curious you
can hook up the etymology for later
these are called heuristics right um the
common common language vernacular
synonym for this is there are rules of
thumb you know the raw values
a rule of thumb is not about power it's
that something that is generally true
something that is generally okay so for
instance it's generally true that in
Rita you should you know wear it on one
that's generally true it's not always
true right but most of the time and this
is where these approaches they're right
most of the time it will give you a
common sense result our results pretty
good might not be the best one but it'll
be pretty accurate
so your intuition smell bad it's not
gonna give you a stupid power but it
might not give you the best one nearest
neighbor also good necessarily the best
right in fact none of these methods that
I'm gonna show you you aren't
necessarily the best they're all
heuristics right so there's the nearest
neighbor one as you can see by the way
if I start somewhere else Francis just
have a look at that pot just get into
you mind if I start somewhere else I
will get a completely different puck for
instance if I were to start
yeah okay where is the arm close to see
I think I go down right down right so
then I'm gonna go now the closest one is
here and then the closest one is all the
way over there and you can clearly see
doesn't take that much meditation see
this is not as good as the first one
like just look at this guy one waist
right in fact what we better is if I did
this and they got rid of that guy
okay but you can see my starting point
will quite dramatically change the
result again the earth everything okay
so what computers do literally is they
crunch through all the different options
okay
they each direct remember that okay so
that was strategy number two let's have
a look at the next one ah the next one
pulls on and you're gonna need yeah
definitely
a new map for this one pulls on what we
did last lesson okay do you remember we
had a look at these guys and look at
these guys remember these guys right
over they call it again space-filling
curves very good so it's a straight line
but the kind of mind we're drawing right
such that we're try to visit every point
in the space in midair yeah as it does
for this particular tip okay does that
sound familiar
we are trying to visit every single
thing that's there so here's the way it
works right I get your alright now what
I want you to superimpose on to your
next empty canvas here is a grid okay
now you look at this grid it's not a
square what like we would do is with the
space-filling curves so would restore a
rectangular space around like so okay
now this what I've just created this is
like that space that square space we
were trying to fill up with now what if
we call the piano curves see if it's a
Hilbert just lot more the best curves
okay so we're gonna subdivide this thing
up until we can fill up with a space for
UK so let's do this right if I divide it
right down the middle you can see you
roughly get square type things
yeah can you see that so I'm gonna treat
each square has its own space that I'm
gonna try to fill okay so for is it what
it is let's see let's go
okay now you can see what I've produced
them what I've done is I have divided
this up and you can see I have a four by
four over here and then another four by
four over here now you saw I divided it
and then I looked at I thought I think I
need to divide again okay the reason I
needed to divide further is because
basically I want no more than one C
square do you see that you see how I I
don't need to really divide out much
better than this because these guys
these guys they were all pretty much any
response yeah that one well we'll see we
can do with that okay again it's a
heuristic right so what we're doing now
is we're taking advantage of a
space-filling curve okay
and it can pick any clothes you like
okay so for example one of the first
ones we did was I think they feel bit
curved remember that guy so the human
curve I believe starts here and yes
do you remember that do you recognize
that shape right now you can see I
filled out this 4x4 I visited all 16
squares and then I've got another one so
I'll just make another copy of the
that's exactly right yes it is that's
exactly what it is now what have I got
now this curve now because it visits
every space in this every point in this
mess okay in theory what I can say now
is this puts these points in an order
okay puts them in order if I follow the
cubic curve around I can say this is the
first point that I mean well they don't
care do you see that
like I haven't met any all the way up
until here the next one I mean is this
one then the next one I mean is this one
you can kind of see what's going on
right now over here yeah I do kind of
have that guy in the borderline but it's
pretty obvious that's gonna be six and
that's gonna be seven I keep going looks
like eight is here nine all the way up
onto him yeah there's my last one eleven
okay so what the hill McCann has done
has provided me an order that's what the
question is like what order should I go
through the examples so now that I have
this I can get rid of the human curve
that he'll become has served its purpose
I could get rid of it all I need is that
order right so are you ready I'm gonna
get rid of it yeah
you can't buy the weight like I mean two
things number one you can read pretty
sure I do care you can do that or
alternatively I had to choose the curve
we have all these other alternatives
that also visit all the space and we
could use those as what and they would
give us different heuristics and
different parts some would be better
than others okay okay now I'm gonna wipe
it off from left to right it's okay if
you're not finished why don't you get
your phone out take a quick snap and
then it's gonna go yeah well but you
know just in case you want to do it like
soon
okay you got ten seconds nine six yeah
we different to what a kids going sorry
I'm just sorry
the Bell's gonna turn on too quickly
this is harder than most
oh my seventh remember I kid you guys
reading that's enough will you see you
clearly enough the outcome
alright let's trace it out ready one two
three four five six nine ten eleven
now I haven't gone ahead and measured
them okay but I do know as all
heuristics - this will give you a pretty
good go right and you can also you can
flip things around and here you can
manually adjust it so I don't know I
don't know if someone got how close this
bears to someone's you know someone's
hair isn't it incredible
give me your one that got 270 yeah now
fantastic okay now obviously what that
means is your intuition might be better
than the rest of us it's certainly not
the first one idea right but can you see
that mathematics produce that curve it
verify that you are just lucky you are
mathematically getting in you know a
very good answer